One of my favorite apps is the Philosophical Calculator. Like
a normal calculator, the first step is to give it
some input. Here we're going to say. Right? And
you got. In Act 4. We
could also supply files. But in this case we're going
to go with a simple prompt. Now the first step
in using the philosophical calculator, of course, is to make
sure we have some models selected. We're going with haiku
and Gemini flash image. And then we start at the
pipeline. Since our input is fairly small, we're going to
skip the summarize notes part and go straight to draft
article. We can run that in the UI and wait
for it to complete. We could view this session. To
monitor it in real time, but this processing session is
a one-stop operation. Its details aren't particularly interesting. For
session detail, we will view that in depth when we
execute lenses, which is next. But
for now, We have the completed draft article. That
is shown in a formatted preview. And now that we
have the draft article, we can proceed to lenses. Here's
where it gets really interesting. The philosophical, philosophical calculator provides
a variety of operations that you can perform on your
draft article. It performs a variety of different analysis like
brainstorming or multi-perspective analysis or even writing a comic book
about the article. For demonstration
purposes, let's go with perspective analysis. I'm going to click
run, and in a second, a session link will pop
up. This session link allows us to monitor
the. Multi-perspective analysis task in real time
as it proceeds through a multi-step reasoning. End
user interface for real time. Um, Agents
For real-time agents and analysis. This will take a moment
because it will be going through a number of different
perspectives and then finally it will synthesize the results, basically
summarize all of the perspectives. We can also in
the main UI go over to usage and we can
monitor the usage as it Uses tokens
So far we have spent about 4 cents on this
process. Oh, the brains, the multi-perspective dialogue is ongoing
so it just use another penny. And
when it completes, the UI will Update. We're only gonna
run this one lens to demonstrate this module, but
you could run each of these, um, if you wanted
to in parallel. Depending on what you felt was appropriate
when these are completed, we can then go back to
the pipeline. And we can update the article which will
take the output of all of the lens runs and
try to fold them back into the article to Pick
up insights and new ideas and other things like that
Perhaps correcting issues. Looking
at lenses, this is almost complete. I saw a synthesis
here. Synthesis is. The last step in the synthesis
is the last step in the multi-perspective analysis. Yeah
And we can see the detailed output for a given
Lens run in the UI. Here we see the multi-perspective
analysis transcript which will detail. Each
perspective in turn. For example, this is the
competitive player perspective. It goes through each perspective, so it's
quite a long analysis, and at the end, you will
find The synthesis and recommendations
section. Here we go. So the lenses
generally involve a very long Set of analysis
and then we'll conclude with a summary. Those summaries and
analysises can again be folded back into the original article
using the pipeline. However, for brevity's sake, we will skip
that and demonstrate one last feature, the illustrate article feature
which is, I think, one of the most entertaining. This
takes your content in your article and designs a number
of illustrations. It can then lead into the article for
Um, there's a display issue. The session link is
shown. In the draft article section. Hopefully, they'll be
fixed and really soon. And again we can monitor this
in real time. It comes up with the image ideas
and then it generates each image. Here
we go. And then after it generates each image. Create
it will integrate the images into the original documents by
editing and now we see our article. Full of illustrations
For 62 cents, we have a fully illustrated guide to
connect 4. This of course was merely
a demo. I hope you enjoy this tool in exploring
your own ideas.